Before we describe the theory as to why this is the case, can you think of any
situations that you've experienced where you saw this bystander effect? That
is, have you been in a situation where somebody really needed help, and there
are a bunch of people around and nobody did help? Have you ever been driving
and noticed a person on the side of the road with a flat tire, or the hood of
their car open with steam coming out of the engine, and just drove by without
stopping to help? Perhaps as you were driving you saw the person and thought,
well somebody must have called to help that person. I'm not the only person who
saw that person needed assistance. Somebody must've called for help. So my
question then, can you think of any situation that you've experienced? This
would be a great time to share it on the forum.